how are you doing Thomas and yourself
a bit anxious
your moods have been up and down yeah
Tom is in recovery from substance use
that began when he was just 16. he's
worked so hard to get here but the
rising cost of living is making him
anxious and he's now worried about a
relapse
I couldn't call we
with things everything we're just
getting really on top of me
and I just didn't know how to escape it
and that's why I started
taking
uh
I've been drug abuse
me I'll screwing down now
yeah
so I don't get really stressed out
and
there's been a few times I've wanted to
take my life
enough
if it weren't for me dogging me befriend
helping me
to get out of me mold swings I'd have
been dead before now
new research has found that around 2.1
million people have increased alcohol
use over the past eight months when
prices started to rise 32 percent of
adults said they had relapsed into
substance use or that someone close to
them had and 61 said the cost of living
crisis was the most significant trigger
unfortunately things like the cost of
living people are going to go back to
substance use as a way of coping with
this and helping with their stress
levels and helping with their anxiety
and it's and it's a scary time out there
for people and we're going to do a swab
now for some in recovery a voluntary
sample with a substance-free result is a
significant step it's hard fought for
and frightening to lose
this is a human catastrophe that we're
facing and people need help they need
help urgently and they need help now
because addiction is at its worst a
killer condition that destroys lives
families Community communities and
ultimately leads to untimely death
last year the government pledged 780
million pounds to drug recovery programs
but with the Autumn budget soon and
signals of economies to come campaign
groups hope that investment remains as
needs grow Catherine evertotsi's Sky
News
now if you are affected by Katarina's
story and want to talk to someone you
can call the Samaritans for free on 116
one two three or you can email Joe
samaritans.org